as you'd expect Excel does things way
more powerful you can quickly have a
calculator but the problem of course is
you've got to open up itself okay so I'm
going to teach you the name of the
function that you need to keep all these
money can you go ahead okay you're here
and in your top cell I want you to type
in this formula and in fact as you start
to type it it should actually start to
recognize and it'll ask you for some
input now as we type it I wonder what
you guess this does okay
now and even actually if you squint you
can see it on your display it tells you
it returns a random number between the
numbers you specify
so if I open brackets the screen there
it says it's looking for two numbers a
bottom and a top right so fun what's a
dump is between one mm I would say one
call to that okay then what we feel that
this is down I can just take this guy
and I can have a whole bunch of them so
once you've got it in a corner like this
you just drag or you can copy paste that
will do too
in fact speaking of copying and pasting
one color mm okay so now the question
for you suppose suppose you wanted to
generate a rare rubbers suppose we look
like a tell you mark off mark it off and
you wanted to generate random numbers to
call on the phone well sometimes there
are lots of ways of the Jews okay if you
want to do this if you want random
random numbers phone numbers aren't just
any kinds of others I keep on the phone
numbers aren't just any kinds of numbers
for example 43 is not a phone number I'm
pretty sure there's no friend of mine do
something else okay what full macro
numbers if you suppose okay so if you
wouldn't if you want to go for a move on
we're expecting something like this you
know something like that
okay so let me teach you how to do this
okay well I'll teach you how to generate
centralian of it this old form this is
just gonna stay what it is right before
so I'll put that to one side then you
want this how many digits do idea that's
going on that's eight digits you want an
eight digit fill but you don't want the
set of digit or two-digit numbers you
want them to be eight digits so he's
having good what's the longest it did
you know but you can think of I saw
another longest the biggest what's the
biggest nine nine nine nine what is the
smallest so I'm gonna copy that down so
you can see now all the numbers were
getting out oh that's interesting is
that
hey what's happened to you that's
interesting
oh that's better
let's try that
that's more like it okay there you go
okay now we're not quite at a arm we're
not quite at a phone number yet because
we don't have any mode for our crop I'll
just teach you something a bit fancy you
never really know now he's speaking I
would have speaker before at the front
of this okay so if you type in third for
something interesting in frustrating
happens you first enter it goes for what
is that it's the same number right so
here's a little trick for you if you
wanted to say before and not for type in
a and in very common can you do that
like just let it eat the quite mark okay
and then type in your zero then it stays
as oh four okay so let me show you that
again if you put that little inverted
comma before what that basically says is
treat this as a piece of text now then
is a number where you would ignore that
from zero meaning zeros will be caught
now I'm going to teach you a fancy word
catenate concatenate is a wee boy it
just means join together so fancy way of
saying that so I'm going to dry to
gether the oh four and also that random
w generated perform like that okay so
now when I generate more random numbers
I just get all the phone numbers do you
see that let me show you again so
there's concatenate it's a weird long
word in concatenate and what if I put it
to this one
what did I put in the oh four comes
first and then your random bit comes
after okay so now if you wanted to you
could take the
like that all I think and then you could
copy it all the way and aha that's
interesting
yes actually that's that's not what I
wanted to let's fix that shall we
that's better and now if you so choose
you can hide all of that and now you
just get this okay any questions make
sense